if you have one sort of radical social
justice activist type young person in
the organization they could open eyes
every sort of protection for feeling
harassed or uncomfortable they have on
the books and there's tons of laws like
that did you happen to see the video
when I was speaking at University of New
Hampshire and like hundreds of
protesters showed up with noisemakers
and they were screaming at me and that's
like everything you could have wrote a
book about it but there was a really
interesting moment so that you know
they're shouting me down and they have
noisemakers and they every few moments
they've set up people to chant yeah and
I keep getting right in their face I
mean as close as we are and say you know
they won't look at me
right they won't look at you because
they don't even want to think you're a
human but I kept saying you know instead
of chanting what you're I'm standing
right in front of you asked me a
question but they won't do any of that
stuff but I bring this up because there
was a moment where an older woman who I
don't know if it was a faculty member or
just the local member of the community
saying started screaming that these
students could be killed when they walk
out of here they could be killed and you
don't care something to that effect and
I thought this is really out of control
like not just the screaming in the rest
of it but the idea that students at the
University of New Hampshire who were all
privileged in the true sense of
privilege I don't care about their skin
color or their gender or their sexuality
privilege in that they're at a great
school where you know you can learn and
you know you're gonna be basically
treated okay and all that but that
people are trying to put the idea in
their mind that they're gonna walk off
campus and be slaughtered and and then
they they start believing it right and
right that it's a matter of being killed
again they might some students might
have grievances that are that I would
agree with that they obviously have
financial because of student loan all
that time I'm starting to similarly and
things like that
they're not literally going to be killed
like that is scaring people and we know
as libertarians when you scare people
that's when you get them fired up to
support like a police state and
government Rouge ins that have all sorts
of negative side effects I mean that was
part of the reason I was pushing back
and then subcommittee
remember when we empower people to do
something because people are scared that
has all sorts of negative consequences
for your Liberty but I had the same
experience when I I saw Charles Marie
speak at Michigan which is my which is
where I graduated from and yet there was
a student screaming at him as he tried
tried and failed to speak because there
was no way to do so that Charles Marie
wanted him dead
hmm and the one thing that sapped kind
of the power of the mob very briefly was
when another student who was a minority
student stood up and said well I don't
think I agree with Charles Marie but I'd
like to hear what he has to say I don't
know how I'm supposed to know what he
thinks unless I actually hear this talk
and that was the thing that so then the
mob doesn't know how to deal with that
right they're not chat when they're when
they're challenged by someone else on
their side another student a faculty
member something like that they can
stand down in some cases because they
are relying on nobody's gonna do
anything to them you know because again
there are minority there's just a small
number of people and they used to do
this and then they would stop because
they would get in trouble or all the
other students would say would you
please shut up I would like to hear the
person and they would you know the they
read the room they knew of people going
to turn on them they're not gonna put
themselves in that position so now it's
the problem has been to last like five
years people are just not doing that
they're letting the the mob shut down
the speaker and they're just afraid to
say anything what do you make of the
self-righteous nature of this the idea
that they walk into these rooms now I
get it they may think that these are
awful people and I won't even
sort of besmirched their intentions
right so they think that they're under
attack and all of these things but what
do you make of the self-righteous nature
that they think that sort of everyone
before them was a bigot and a racist or
an idiot or a buffoon or somehow evil
but not only that they also think that
all of their equals the the students
that they're that are their equals
should be basically silenced because
they don't even have the opportunity
like that kid wanted to hear the speaker
write free speech is a double right
that's actually something Frederick
Douglass said there's it's the right to
be heard as well as the right to speak I
mean all these other students would
probably like to hear this person again
even if they don't agree with the person
one of one of my formative experiences
as an undergraduate was I was running
for the campus paper and I went to cover
an event that Bill Ayers this radical
Weather Underground domestic terror is
whatever you want to call him he was
speaking and I
interviewed him for the paper and I
thought that was so cool I'm
interviewing you know a historical
figure I'm a young person who wants to
be a journalist like that was a really
cool educational experience for me I
mean that doesn't mean you agree with
everything he said but think it's like
conservatives had been running the
campus then or if rare concerns that a
dangerous or person it is the exact same
thing he makes us feel unsafe he
shouldn't be allowed on campus and there
were Republican legislators who said it
that exact thing right well he did
commit actually so it's a little bit
different but I get I get the point but
but so it's you know it's it's college
you're there to learn from interesting
people you're paying a ton of money to
do it to deprive the other students of
their opportunity to hear and to speak
and to question these people again an
experience that they're paying an
exorbitant amount of money to have
there's just a selfishness to doing that
but again they say we are obligated
because we our people's lives are on the
line and we are protecting people's
safety their emotional comfort is on the
line if they don't feel this is a home
to them and you can't bring this awful
racist person into our home or this
person who some awful racist person
maybe retweeted or quoted once you can't
bring them into our home it's our home
and that's wrong yeah
and someone needs to tell them it's
actually not their home I mean that's
what the girl that was yelling at Nick
Christakis kept saying right this is
supposed to be our home they're our home
but no it's actually not your home it's
your place where you're supposed to
everybody does want to feel comfort on
some level right they comfort it comfort
is is a natural yeah I'm not gonna bash
it for wanting there to be some like
level of civility maybe but they're not
practicing civility when they do these
things so it's you know they're
screaming at people so and and again
it's not it's not exactly if it's a
public university campus I mean they're
supposed to be in the public square
they're supposed to be uncomfortable
speech people can you know chalk
horrible things about Trump or whoever
the Republican president is they did
that at Michigan when I was there the
crazy homophobic preacher can scream
crazy Westboro Baptist Church like
things in the public square I mean these
used to be things that like the the
progressive ACLU type consensus said
like note we're gonna allow and these
students completely reject that view and
in fact they hate the ACLU for even once
having it and we'd like them to unhappy
as soon as possible which
sort of the ACLU is kind of flaking on
some of these things at this point right
yeah there there are some real concerns
I think the organization itself is
trying to figure out how it can appease
the kind of progressives that want it to
fall to not hold so tightly to those
commitments and but I think a lot of you
with the ACLU want told to those
commitments but they just don't know
exactly but it really is in tension with
these very loud even some of the people
who work for them again I the theme of
the book is it only takes one if you
have one sort of radical social justice
activist type young person in the
organization they can they weaponize
every sort of protection for feeling
harassed or uncomfortable they have on
the books and there's tons of laws like
that title nine of the university's
other titles for for private sector
businesses and they can make it so that
you just can't have difficult or
uncomfortable conversations in the in
the college and in the firm that's why
it's so fascinating what's going on with
them because it's like you guys used to
defend everybody's right all the time
you know the Skokie case obviously is
the big one nadine strossen her book
hate yeah you know it's like and she's
Saturday by the way I'm not bad no she's
incredible but she's not worse she's not
working there anymore and you can see
how social justice has has just sort of
infected I mean the Westboro Baptist
Church case I mean these were people
screaming at military servicemen who had
died for their kind of screaming
horrible things about them if that
speech hate speech is protected on the
First Amendment
everything that the charles murray says
or whatever the students are upset about
is clearly protected but when i they
also don't have a very good education
about the First Amendment which isn't
just them that's just the whole country
you know when you quiz people on what
nobody knows for reason maybe for
reasons we discussed earlier in this
interview but so they many of them think
hate speech is already illegal
I talked to activists who said I just
want the college to bring its it's hate
speech policy in line with federal
speech law what they do yes it's already
like put in line by not having having
one yeah and by the way that's not
really what they want because if they
understood what it was they would that's
the last thing that they want they don't
want that exchange
you mentioned universe Arizona State
yeah so I was at Arizona State about a
year year and a half ago I was speaking
there with Michael Shermer from skeptic
magazine and I did this little thing I
sometimes I do when I'm doing stand-up
where I just kind of pulled the crowd
you know how many conservatives are here
how many liberals here progresses well
then at the end I said how many Nazis
are here and usually usually nobody
applauds one person in the back a woman
started applauding that she was a Nazi
so I said to her I said all right that
was kind of surprising and and
everyone's looking at her and it's all
kind of awkward I said but when we get
to the Q&A I will gladly give you the
microphone first then you can share your
Nazi thoughts anyway we do that we do
just that and she goes on and on about
how the Holocaust is a hoax and she and
Michael Shermer who's debunked a lot of
these Holocaust skeptics she asks him
some questions and he just has all the
facts and he just you know smacks her
down in a totally respectful way but
sort of puts her in her place with facts
I mention all this because it turns out
that this act this Nazi was a trans
woman which I just think it's just sort
of hilarious in like just
intersectionality beautiful in just the
psychotic Verte way that
intersectionality works or doesn't work
it was a trans woman identifying as a
Nazi and I thought that is real you know
it's funny you mentioned having a Nazi
in your crowd so I in part of the
research I did for this book I found out
that and in nineteen it was either 1963
or 1964 the progressive student group at
Berkeley you know this is right after in
the middle of the Berkeley Free Speech
Movement where you have progressive
students and conservative students ever
the students really rising up and saying
no we're gonna have whatever speakers on
campus we want we're do whatever
political organizing we want the
administration can't tell us we can't
that was the Free Speech Movement the
progressive student group was so
committed to free speech that they
invited a member of a Nazi of a member
of a neo-nazi group to campus to speak
not only did they invite him to speak
they all dressed up in full Nazi regalia
for it to promote this
event those again and this is in 1963
this was only like 20 years removed from
the actual threat of Nazism versus today
and nobody heckled the guy he would make
his remarks and then they'd laugh at him
and when he was done he went off and
that was that there was no you know
there was no crisis of safety on the
campus no one shut him down can you
imagine if they did that today I mean
Bert well they'd already been in the
place down what they'd reburn it right
but now when we are you know much
further removed from from the threat of
actual Nazism you couldn't you couldn't
never do that and this was the
progressive students who thought it was
important to make a a do a free speech
stunt and B what is the harm from
hearing from a Nazi will learn how
abhorrent and dumb Nazism is yeah you
know if you want a four so winning
Richard Spencer speaking in campus for
instance shutting him down or screaming
at him or getting violent is exactly
what he would Congrats exactly what he
wants he gets to say look at the
intolerant left look at what they'll do
they're gonna do this to me they'll do
this to you next if just he gives his
remarks to like an empty stadium or like
three actual Nazis there that's an
that's probably bear Assange for him you
don't like don't show up with the violet
you're playing into their hands yeah
let's talk about some of this sort of
subgroups that go on in this because you
know we always talk about sort of the
left and the right and it does seem like
it's coming more of an alep these days
but what give me some of the just the
subgroups on each side that are bubbling
up sure so I did a lot of work on since
I read about sexual harassment and
sexual assault and the title nine stuff
on campus one of my chapters is about
title nine related activism fourth wave
feminism and what has happened on campus
because of them that's a chapter that I
care a lot about because I write a lot
about that then when you were writing
this title nine was still in it yes
right this is the only one that has sort
of a there's a good news resolution that
and again I disagree with a lot of
things the trouble administration does
but Betsy DeVos the Secretary of
Education changed the guidance related
to title nine in a way that I absolutely
applaud so this is this is a federal
statute from the 70s it's one sentence
long it's attached to the law that funds
higher ed
the L education funds all education if
you get federal funds for your school
you have to you can't discriminate on
the basis of sex or on the basis of
gender that's all it says perfect that's
perfectly benign it was intended you
know if you have a male sports team and
there's comparative interest in having a
you know you don't have to have a girl
sports team if no one wants to play but
if you have people who want to play you
have to fund that team dude you're not
going to force women to play football
but if there's nothing show up well I
mean we were probably getting to that
but originally in the 1970s that was not
what was going on yeah under the Obama
administration the assistant secretary
the bureaucrat under this who was
charged with making sure universities
are complying with title nine started
interpreting it much more broadly to
include her harassment and sexual
assault and they were defining these
terms so broadly that sort of anything
that made someone feel feel
uncomfortable for a reason of sex or
gender could be considered a title nine
problem now it wouldn't actually be if
you brought this before court or
something that that wouldn't happen but
universities are compliance places so if
you have this big government bureaucracy
telling you well we kind of think you
should do it this way you're not gonna
fight him you're gonna you're gonna roll
over so they rolled over in ways that
we're just disastrous for free speech
because again speech related to sex and
gender they're saying well if you're
making people uncomfortable for that
reason it violates the federal law and
also a due process so when there is a
student accused of sexual misconduct
they were saying well we would like you
to adjudicate this under this standard
and we really don't want you to have any
like cross examination at the hearing
and we don't want you do any of these
other things so they were they were
literally obliterating due process they
really were for I mean there have been a
hundred lawsuits brought by student
usually male students often athletes
often male students of color by the way
or immigrants
again the normal issues in the criminal
justice system where black people get
arrested more for things totally true in
the university bureaucracy as well the
students sued for saying I was I was
wrongfully accused or regardless of
whether it was wrongful or not you
violated my rights in a due process
sense and they and when it goes to
what they win and then they sue the
universe the university's work just
caught cuz they're like well the
government is going to yank our funding
if we don't do it the way they say but
we're gonna get sued and lose because
this is ridiculous this is a farce
mm-hmm
and this was all because of this this
guidance from the Obama administration
but then it was so the activist
component is activists the guidance
comes out in 2011 sort of feminist
activists on campus I think started
quickly realized within a few years of
that that title nine now was this great
tool for adjudicating grievances or for
punishing people who engaged in speech
the way you didn't like I mean there's
literally an activist group where the
leaders of it got the numeral nine
tattooed to their ankles because that is
how important this interpretation has
been to to feminist activism and they
you said Laura Kipnis he's probably
someone you're familiar with he was a
pastor but I there's all these cases
there there are cases that were never
famous you know where someone just got
like an F on their on their exam because
they wrote the name of their instructor
wrong on it and someone said you wrote
well that's a pornographic actresses
name so you intended this as a sexual
slur so so that and and the professor
actually said so we're concerned this
would violate title 9 again it wouldn't
right it's not what the statute means
right no court would agree with you but
and what about those two kids were there
there was the one case the two college
students guy and a girl that were
hooking up and then they both went after
each other for a title nine because they
were basically trying to preempt each
other yes that's right that started
becoming like legitimately a thing if
you had a sort of sketchy sexual
encounter which is the case in many of
these they disciplined all right this
isn't you know someone broke into your
dorm room and and you were like hold
held their hand over your mouth this is
we were drunk we were doing drugs
it began consensually or we sort of
intended to do something and I don't
remember what happened now I'm
uncomfortable about it and and maybe
something bad or violence and policy did
happen I mean these are hard to
adjudicate anyway right because they
were lying and hazy alcohol is a factor
in the overwhelming majority of these
cases mm-hmm so but so then you wake up
from this encounter and the first
reporter
as a huge advantage to these title nine
cases so the I saw I'm starting to see
cases where you had the mail go to the
title nine office first to accuse the
woman just to be terrible then she would
do it
you know I saw cases where I we're a
fleeting kiss became a title my issue
where the normal just human courtship
again I'm not I'm not saying sexual
assault it's not a bit is not a problem
on campuses or wherever else but things
that should not have been handled by
campus authorities we're being handled
by campus authorities things that might
have been regrettable or bad or some or
maybe they should learn you know don't
drink so much into the male and the
female lessons are not being learned
this is immediately going to sort of a
criminal matter that that can just that
can destroy people's lives on both sides
I mean to get expelled from college for
rape I mean that is a huge financial
like hit that you're going to take never
having a trial for rape lawyer I mean
these policy said you couldn't have a
lawyer there one of the things devos has
done is said yes there has to be there
has to be a lawyer there the student
wants a lawyer who can ask questions of
the other side you don't have to have
the man and the girl and questioning
each other but you have to have at least
questions interchange I mean at some of
these hearings you were having not even
panels they were starting to get away
with do away with panels where was one
administrator was investigating the case
was deciding which witnesses to just to
talk to there was a there was a case
where the the accused a again a male
black football player said what can you
interview like all these people who know
including one time the the victim
because she had not filed a complaint
they were like dating and it was someone
else who didn't like their relationship
so this person filed a complaint yeah so
a third party could file a complaint it
that is obligated to if they became
knowledgeable of alleged or suspected or
possible violation of title now that is
obligated 22 yeah I'm watching there's a
hulu mini-series on it right now I'm
watching it it's great it's exactly that
so so you had cases where again there's
no actual dispute and they're being
adjudicated
and I got it spelled the unity
administrator would not talk would not
interview the people who knew this is
all nonsense
he said no it's my job to determine who
I speak with and then you can't and then
he publicly creates a report he wasn't
even he wasn't even recording his
interviews he was just it was just his
recollection of who he talked to and
this is no standard practice across the
board for the single investigator model
which was becoming very important and
then the new guidance has gotten rid of
thank God yeah man that is some evil
stuff so it I find this the title nine
stuff so interesting on so many levels
because there's sort of this social
justice level there's a legal level
there's a there's a sort of fundamental
sort of classically liberal due process
yeah
if you're accused of something you you
should be able to defend yourself and
use all the powers of the law that would
allow you to do that yes but the other
part that I think is interesting is I
remember when DeVos reversed all of
these things that you're laying out of
why they're so wrong
I remember the the you know blue cheque
celebrity Twitterati and the Bell the
Bette Midler's and Sarah Silverman's and
the the progressives on Twitter
basically all set Trump hates women he's
Pro rape all of these things and it's
light and then you look in it's like
well these things get fifty thousand
retweets and eighty thousand retweets
and it all sounds right Trump's removing
protections from rape victims and it's
like I better scream about that it
sounds right and they never want to hear
any of the things you just said the
uncomfortable truths right you laid out
there and breaking that well it's very
similar to breaking the the white
supremacy argument that you're trying to
break is yeah they don't want to hear I
mean
complicated narratives are less sexy for
reporting they don't want to hear that
actually this is kind of a problem and
anyone who's like studied this you know
this issue in any seriousness knows that
the existing system just wasn't working
and again like I was saying it was
causing lawsuits from both sides and the
universities cannot handle this under
that you know that's like a complicated
thing the nope this isn't
further evidence that the administration
is waging its war on women that isn't
easier sort of headline so much of the
reporting when de Vos changed this stuff
was just was just it was clear they
hadn't even read what the new guidance
was going to be in their defense it was
very long I guess yeah
but there
was completely disconnected so I saw
some journalist there's a journalist at
Slate actually who's covered these
things a little better and he was saying
and he when he wrote about he's like
yeah this was actually there were some
problems here I don't know if a new
approach is better but like there was
this was not exactly working people
who'd studied the problem a little bit
more closely knew that but the activists
I mean the activists knew that but they
wanted it to still be the other way
because they they did not take the like
enlightenment liberal view that these
people deserve due process they think it
would be better you know if if everyone
is expelled even if you know half of
them are innocent
as long as long as we got the other half
which is just like a total inversion
right of kind of the Enlightenment
principle that it's better you know that
guilty men go free than to put away even
one innocent person that's like the the
bedrock of our classically liberal
Western understanding of justice and
they were just they were utterly against
and they'd say well you know we're not
sending these people to jail we're doing
their lives making them unemployable
forever yeah but yeah yeah so what what
are some of the others sort of subgroups
that you dive into here because the
fascinating thing I thought was there
because of the way the internet is and
message boards and message boards or
people message boards whatever whatever
they the little groups are and telegram
and all of these everything that all of
these little niche very very niche
groups that often have these competing
interests they're all popping up and
it's hard to really it's hard to gather
and I talk about this like how much
actual influence they have how much
momentum they have what they're really
trying to do how much of it is just
purely trolling and just trying to turn
things and all that well I'll talk about
the one that's actually doing the best
right now which is the democratic
socialists of America unlike many of the
other groups
I studied they are highly organized they
had clearly had a lot of people in them
and they're and they're poised to have a
big impact they I can't underestimate or
overstate rather their dramatic increase
in the last few years I looked at some
of the numbers for these groups of this
group this is the far left economic
Bernie Sanders esque group yeah that was
just a bunch of old hippies I'd like
there were a couple thousand of them
from
from when the group started in the late
70s or 80s or whenever it was up until
three years ago it was the same people
nothing had changed they've done 30
years older
yeah but they had not added a single new
member or had a single new subscription
for their for their publications in the
last three years the average age of one
of their members has dropped from like
90 thousand to thirty these are highly
motivated young people who who are
passionate about socialism we talk a lot
about cultural issues but what animates
them is the economics the the economic
inequality I interviewed people who said
things like you know capitalism is the
most evil system ever devised and we're
gonna convince people that socialism is
good that their private university
holding a knife oh right right right
right
and they but and but they also hate
something that makes them similar to
some of the other groups again they hate
liberalism broadly they hate sort of
moderate liberalism like the the norm II
know normies right
they hate the gist and that's everyone
from like Hillary Clinton to me in the
spectrum are people who like broadly
like free trade in markets and stuff I
guess yeah we're all the same we're all
just normal Ibrahim clued myself in that
to probably they hate us more in a way
than they hate the Conservatives right
there because there's like because they
think we're sort of faking it or
something like that well and Trump is
weird for them because while Trump you
know is like the most
hey table for a lot of these other
intersectionality groups for sort of
like cultural reasons and things he says
about immigrants women so on for them
you know they actually share some of
like the trade just not liking and just
kind of dislike a business that
occasionally Trump has sort of you know
kind of the dressed or talked about that
that makes out also they think the rush
of stuff is stupid because they kind of
like Russia probably for they admire
sort of communism or something like that
right so it's it's actually weird to see
them not as worked up about Trump in the
exact say I don't say there
not pro Trump at all they still hate him
but but they hate they hate Democrats
liberals neo liberals who are like
squishy and like markets sometime and
are not radical enough you know they
don't want Joe Biden is just as bad as
anyone else it's Bernie may be Warren no
one else everyone else is equally is is
is tainted by the same original sin of
liberalism do you think there is any
chance any chance whatsoever that the
modern democratic party not that I have
any love for the modern democratic party
but can it can the shell of that thing
survive this or are they going to
completely dismantle any remaining
liberal and and JFK will be will be
you know his memory will be destroyed -
in the course of all that that goes
they'll have to well here's some moment
some moment for hope I think it's going
to be a lot harder for them to do this
then maybe they expect right now they're
riding high on victory they got AOC in
there you know Bernie is really popular
they they think it's their moment you
know moments don't often last as long as
the people who are here and some of them
think they're gonna have a lot more
difficulty sort of just convincing
you're just sort of regular older maybe
even religiously inclined normal sort of
Midwest rest of America Democrat not not
Republic Democrat a lot of those - right
so they're gonna have trouble getting
the people that got constantly saying or
Harl the people who just like Biden yeah
there are a lot of people out there who
just like him because he was a vice
president he and again people who are
not as motivated to know every detail of
policy the way your activist woke set is
right but I guess my question is do you
think so let's say I mean conventional
thinking if you just look at the polls
and I hate polls but it's basically like
Biden is is crushing it right yeah he's
up by 2030 points over over Bernie and
most of the polls and maybe to your
point Bernie or D Pete four years ago so
maybe it's already over
but that they will have to destroy him
that it will cause such a rupture in the
party that I that it may be what the
natural entropy of it is is that the
party actually does have to split in two
and I think there's a version of this
for conservatives and Republicans as
well this is this is a this fracturing
taking place on both sides is very
interesting right now
yeah Republicans as well are kind of
breaking into this more populist tea in
the vein of Trump versus I'm sure you've
seen some of this fighting between
National Review and first things people
over a more kind of libertarian I mean
lightly libertarian not even as
libertarian as I am version of the
Republican Party that maybe existed yeah
I'm enjoying watching that fight very
because it's it's David French and Saura
Amar'e Amar'e yeah and I've been
watching it going or this is how an
intellectual fights po7 you guys are
fighting for the heart of what you think
conservatism is supposed to be and it's
basically being done respectfully and I
think they're gonna sit down I'd be
happy to host it here it's like it's
like wow there's something cool going on
there but that's not how the fight is
going down on the other side yeah I mean
I do see similarities though because
again it's because one of the sides sees
itself is ascendant they think their
political moment has arrived and maybe
it has I mean maybe both of these things
could go the direction of you're gonna
have a more nationalist
trade and immigrants skeptical you
already have an immigrant skeptical but
also very trade skeptical of Republican
Party and you're going to have a sort of
much further left socialist inclined
Democratic Party the way you have in
Europe the problem is with the American
system we like because of the way we're
device we always just have the two
parties whereas in Europe you can have
both of these parties and then a
spectrum of more libertarian or more
centrist or more moderate parties I
think it would help it have that we
can't or do you think the system is
right but do you think if we had a
little more of a coalition based system
where people because the idea that these
broad blankets have left or right public
concern it doesn't really fit anymore do
you think a coalition system might I
mean they've got all sorts of problems
because the coalition's because this
tiny parties have absurd power you can
take out anybody at any time I'm always
skeptical that any kind of the tweaks to
how the system of votes are tallied will
ever translate to anything being better
for what I want but yes I would I would
prefer if sort of libertarian inclined
people could ally with certain groups on
select issues
but like maintain our own identity and
right now it's just you have to fall
under the umbrella of one or the other
which is frustrating cuz we're at a
moment where I think both parties are
moving away from I mean that's part of
the theme of that I talked about in the
book of the extremes and then there's a
radicalizing taking place on on both
obviously on campus and in social media
we see the influence of the left but I
try not to you know again I don't want
to overstate you campus and Twitter or
not the whole world
Republicans have control of government
so you think there's a way you can maybe
split the difference or something like
one idea that sort of makes sense to me
is like because I would love a somewhat
functional libertarian party but you
know that if if a fun if a libertarian
party got in and got 5% which they never
get five five my god it would be it
would be incredible but you know what
would happen of course it would lead to
probably president Bernie or something
like that so I don't want that so the
idea may be that what if you had
something where you could vote for the
whatever a third party you want and then
once the the three percent checks in so
there's the election now three percent
checks in and now you know they're not
going to do anything with that three
percent that then they could decide
where they're gonna give their support
so that people could at least still feel
good about the original vote does that
make sense something like that yeah like
I'm just trying because so many people
are gonna be disgusted at what they have
to do at the next election and they were
already discussed it last time and I
think the more we keep having to be
disgusted just the more people will just
check out yeah politics is is by its
very nature disgusting right we're
deciding which policies the entire
country all 300 or 400 million people
are going to have to live under which
you know which tyrant will be oppressing
them on which things we because we have
a just sort of unitary system where the
executive gets to do everything Congress
has delegated all its authority to the
president whoever the whoever the
president is not to Trump but to the
office of the president yeah so they're
always happy to take more to that power
yeah yeah and comment Congress has been
a they know you can decide they don't
even Congress doesn't even weigh in when
we're like declaring war they're like no
you get to I can choose who we bomb we
don't really care which is and actually
I think the Supreme Court has
consumption in some sense stood up and
is playing a role of Congress by almost
adjudicating policy more directly then
maybe they were intended to do because
there's just no body to put like
separate from the president from the
Office of the President Congress is just
a is just a is just rubber-stamp
but again and we have this big country
where these rules will be for everyone
people who live in Florida people who
live in California people who live in
Iowa and Michigan all have to listen to
even though we have different values and
might care about different things
because of this just immense central
government which is not the way was
intended to be and makes us all mad at
each other on Twitter and everywhere
else
let's decentralize the whole damn thing
yes I've thoroughly enjoyed this
conversation Robi thank you my fellow
I'm still alert about the haier haier
beyond that it was pretty definitely
your issue in the election lower hair
for more on Robi follow him on twitter
at robbie suave
[Music]